das hotel adlon kempinski ist eines der
luxuriösesten und bekanntesten hotels in
deutschland wenn ich sogar eigentlich
das bekannteste würde mal sagen es liegt
im berliner ortsteil mitte am boulevard
unter den linden 77 unweit des
brandenburger tors am pariser platz das
adlon ist ein weiteres fünf sterne
superior hotel und würde ich mal sagen
das passt in deutschland lasst uns mal
herausfinden leute was geht ab wir
mittlerweile schon tag 3 form einer
berlin-reise ich bin halt ein bisschen
unterwegs und hinter mir könnt ihr sehen
ich sitze hier gerade am brandenburger
tor und ja ich hab mir gedacht ich muss
eigentlich von tag zu tag steigern
werden heute im dritten tag auf den
letzten tag und heute nacht alter ich
wollte es auch schon immer mal machen es
ist ja eigentlich so das krasseste hotel
was man in deutschland kennt oder was
international bekanntes aus deutschland
und zwar ist das brandenburger tor und
hinter mir auf der anderen seite waren
genau da ist das atmen und abhängig
heute hat nur 400 euro gekostet wir
haben jetzt 20 vor zwei eigentlich kann
ich erst um 15 uhr einchecken aber ich
probiere mal trotzdem schon rein zu
kommen vielleicht sind ja so leid moment
ist eine kamera saubermachen es meinen
wenn man schon 400 euro bezahlt kann man
da vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr
rein ich bin hier an diesem ort auch
schon ewig nicht mehr gewesen bestimmt
über zehn jahre leute kriegen jetzt mal
rein ich musste aufpassen weil man das
glaube ich nicht film da sind halt oft
auch so stars und so kennt man ja außer
michael metzger guck mal hier
seifenblasen so hey leute ich bin so
gespannt also ich war ja letzte woche in
köln im besten hotel der check dass
viele gerne ab wenn es noch nicht
gesehen habt jetzt bin ich auf jeden
fall noch deutlich gespart weil das hier
ist glaube ich noch mal eine andere
nummer
so hotel adlon kempinski also kasse
autos stehen jetzt aber noch nicht was
ist das sind 2 gegen als die namen
einiger ausrutscher mal schnell ein
rezeptionist da als wir danke
und hat uns immer reserviert doch so ist
macht man hier ich will auch mal
okay das war eine tolle chance haben
sich auch
hervorragend da und
zwar sie bleiben ja bei uns ist mir
einfach dass er genau so ein glücklicher
gebucht sind ja bereits das cover mit
das habe ich gemacht ja wunderbar
entweder bekommen sie auch die vorzüge
von queen weckruf die partie vielleicht
ja gerne um die uhr denn zehn und 30
thomas uber beim kaffeetrinken sind ab
dem cappuccino mit normaler will ja
genau
dankeschön vielleicht interessiert haben
ja das ist ja interessant ist im moment
im namen der zimmermann einfach super ja
ich bin ein bisschen früh aber dachte
wird schon
nämlich selber er das geht jetzt nicht
mehr vielen dank
rang so
leute wunderbar ab ein aufzug
und auch die
ich werde nur auf zu ich hab zwar okay
jetzt sind wir gespannt ich hoffe es
wird sich lohnen es hat nicht lange
gedauert gerade da unten aber ist halt
so ne also bisher
jetzt wenn jemand zu sehen ganz gut aus
ich habe war das erzähle ich euch gleich
wenn ich im zimmer bin mama ich bin im
adlon
ohne dass ich irgendwann mal in st
bitte nicht stören
danke angekommen
erst mal ausziehen wtf
ja leute ich finde es immer angekommen
ich würde sagen wir lieber gar nicht
lange ich zeige es euch mal eben es
sieht wirklich ich finde es besser als
das excelsior in köln muss ich sagen
irgendwie auch noch mal ein bisschen
größer da ist glaube ich ein kleiner
strand wo man reingehen kann ja wir
erkunden das jetzt zusammen hier kommt
man rein hier kann man dann irgendwie
wird auswählen zack zack hier sind
schränke aha regenschirm an dann geht
das licht an gerade mantel dance bar
bereich werde ich auf jeden fall mal
abstecken hier das schwimmen war doch
auch wissen dass alles noch welche
weiter
so langweilig hier bin ich und hier
schwenk mir rüber und kommen dann ins
vierte zimmer also da brauche ich
eigentlich nicht zu sagen das ist schon
wirklich also das ist das krasseste
hotelzimmer in dem ich hier war mit
abstand also dass in köln war auch schon
krank aber das hier ist glaube ich noch
mal eine schippe mehr weiß ich aber gar
nicht was hier mal hier auch hier haben
wir das bad
mit badewanne licht an hier kommen wir
rein haben hier die badewanne
rega alter geisteskrank
und dann haben wir hier das ist das auch
so die dusche man kann sich auch
hinsetzen natürlich man kann sich im
letzten und hier haben wir dann zum klo
okay man muss natürlich sagen alles ein
bisschen altmodisch das merkt man aber
das ist halt das adlon also hier sehe
ich mich auf jeden fall heute nacht
nicht macht also heute abend ein bad
nehmen aber wir sind ja längst noch
nicht am ende der erkundung fernseher
könnte ein bisschen größer sein nein
reicht völlig aus die leute das ist doch
so ein richtiger präsidenten
schreibtisch oder direkt mit der karte
von der minibar heißgetränk was kostet
hier in de ja okay
wir machen ein kurzes preise raten
breakfast aller card frisch gepresster
orangensaft oder grapefruitsaft schreibt
gehen in die kommentare was ihr raten
würde sonst merkt euch kurz im kopf und
dann sage ich ja schon die lösung in 5 4
3 2 1
orangensaft
25 das ist eine ansage wiener schnitzel
vom kalb 29 euro hat das geht ja
eigentlich dann sogar wieder nur
kännchen kaffee 12 euro 90 cappuccino 97
kann man nicht meckern okay ich wollte
auf jeden fall später mal den döner
probieren hier gibt es ja vermutlich den
teuersten trainer der welt für 19 euro
glaube ich kostet der dann machen wir
hier immer weiter wir haben wir den safe
ok café set machte mir gleich mal einen
leckeren cappuccino und hier dann denke
ich mal die minibar unten drin das weiß
ich jetzt natürlich nicht ob das hier
alles mit dem preis drin ist ich denke
mal er nicht nur die kosten
wahrscheinlich
original haribo mit hotel adlon
verpackung die sind auch lecker die
dinge schauen wir mal in die minibar das
wird ja safe die krasseste mini wasilla
okay es geht die ist auf jeden fall
schon in ordnung würde ich mal sagen
ungefähr gleich zu setzen mit der
minibar im excelsior in köln aber gut so
was hatten die da halt nicht nur hier
und dann gucken wir mal raus hier haben
wir den innenhof vom adlon auch kasten
also es sieht schon sehr sehr
majestätisch alles aus und ich muss
erstmal klar kommen zur aus- und ab aufs
bett klassische vorwärts wolle
bisschen dunkel aber hier drinnen
momente an die zimmer aufräumen
beschuldigung theoretisch habe ich hier
so einen kleinen balkon schaut mal leute
hier würde ich rauchen dann könnte ich
hier einfach rausgehen aber ich brauche
zum glück nicht ich habe mir auf jeden
fall ist mein kaffee gemacht und saßen
sie noch ein bisschen arbeiten eine
sache ich noch sagen und zu habe ich
früher diesem film geliebte emil und die
detektive und der spielt auf ihrem adler
und deswegen fand ich es noch cooler
ebenso durch diese gänge zu gehen und er
ist auch alles schon recht lange her
aber könnte aber in die kommentare
schreiben mit dem film kennt ich melde
mich später wieder wenn essen gibt oder
ich im pool gehe auch eine badehose ich
habe eine badehose vergessen aber ich
denke die können mir bestimmt irgendwo
helfen bis später andere kämen kurz
leute draußen ist schon dunkel ich bin
jetzt fertig und ich kann jetzt endlich
mal schwimmen gehen problem ist ich
wollte ohne badehose deswegen dachte ich
rufe ich mal eben unten an ob du eine
badehose für mich haben und dort mal
hier ich bin gerade im fernsehen rtl
auch wird sich so hey leute es ist
einfach zu kranken ich gehe es ein
wellness bereich wir sind die schlappen
sind sondern zum geschenk eingepackt ich
nehme ich mein handy mit kamera dem ich
natürlich nicht mit darunter hat bin
echt gespannt ich glaube das wird krank
auf die letzte und auch nur ein stück
studiert band
[Musik]
hier ist auch schon mal schön warm - 1
let's go
etwas geht alter geistig kein filme ich
bin ganz alleine
weil war schon schön schon das world
riesen schwimmbecken nur durch ihr gebt
euch mal wie das alles hier ist einfach
niemand dann können sie diese thema und
da sind früchte das ist schon schön geld
nicht so lässt sich das auf jeden fall
aushalten
[Musik]
leute es ist wirklich so wie
er mit abstand das krasseste hotel in
dem ich je war es waren ist mit name und
so und die leute da so freudig eine fast
zu freundlich weitere die wollen alles
für dich machen naja hab ich jetzt auch
hinter mir jetzt rückt die gäste was
geht ich studiere vom schwimmbad hat mir
gerade was zu essen bestellt und hier
hinter mir ist jetzt soll das bad
eingelassen das nikon setzt du dich
meine badewanne
gestellt habe ich gerade für warte mal
26 euro den döner kebab da wird doch ein
extra video zu geben check das auf jeden
fall ab wenn es kommt und ich bin mal
gespannt wie das schmeckt so weiter wir
haben mittlerweile fünf von neun ich hab
noch frisch geduscht abgewartet und so
weiter und jetzt teilgenommen ein paar
freuen das wird euch noch wilde nach dem
bahrain gp auf jeden fall leute die
dusche so leisten die ist komplett
ausgefüllt mit wasser also stellt sich
darunter des films immer lokalisierungs
morgen wieder ich wünsche euch eine gute
nacht reingeguckt leute was geht dir
haben wir halb fünf also ohne scheiß hat
noch eine ganz wilde sause mit jonas
heiko und noch ganz lang und ich musste
erst mal was essen und jetzt kamen die
hier gerade mit seinem
mit so einem tisch halt wer mit dem
tisch nice muss das kurz erst dann gehe
ich schlafen die leute was geht guten
morgen panama schied aus ich habe gerade
den kaffee bekommen guten morgen weckruf
kann der kapo tieren
danke dann trinke ich jetzt erstmal muss
sagen ich habe wirklich sensationell
geschlafen aber nicht lange leute was
ihr tut ich muss jetzt auschecken sie
muss ich eigentlich ganz gut aus einer
bis auf doch kann man so hinterlassen
würde ich sagen oder
so leute was gedacht ich bin
mittlerweile wieder zu hause und muss
euch ja noch ein zwei sachen zum atmen
sagen wie ich mir gefallen hat was sich
so geben würde an punkten und ob ich
euch das empfehlen würde dort mal
hinzugehen für 400 euro ich glaube ich
habe einmal ein video gesagt dass dort
und nacht so um die 400 euro kostet
bezahlt habe ich für diese nach 4 19
euro plus dann noch zweimal
zimmerservice fluss die ladebuchse die
ich mir gekauft habt also insgesamt
danken wir bei 481 euro hab ich gerade
gesehen wurde von meiner visa card
abgebucht das ist natürlich schön aber
ich war letztens auch im teuersten
luxushotel in köln im excelsior und darf
ich auch gesagt ich würde da niemals so
privat ein check mit ist ja klar aber
ich muss sagen das adlon war noch mal
eine schippe besser als das excelsior
einfach vom ganzen gesamtpaket er dieses
personal da du hast doch mal gemerkt ich
sind so noch mal anders geschult keine
ahnung die reden anders ist hotel
menschen ihr hab das sicherlich 12 mal
im video gehört es war mir schon
unangenehm dass alle leute die dir
begegnen die wollen alles für dich
machen also wirklich ich war ja unten
auch noch im schwimmbad im marmor
schwimmbad also ich glaube das war alles
marmor und das personal da die karmann
dauern auf mich zu optimieren etwas
gutes tun können oder keine ahnung jetzt
war fast schon nervig trotzdem muss ich
sagen man fühlt sich dort wirklich sehr
sehr gut aufgehoben das zimmer war
extrem groß geräumig das bad war einfach
geil ich habe mich wohl gefühlt ich
würde es natürlich nicht noch mal machen
aber es war eine krasse erfahrung und
ich muss sagen für dieses hotel es gab
eigentlich nichts bis auf den preis an
dem man jetzt was auszusetzen haben muss
gut solche hotels sondern ebenso teuer
bei max älter und köln habe ich 9,5 von
zehn punkte geben hier muss ich dann
ganz klar sieben von zehn geben also das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz geistes kann
das hotel schon froh dass ich da mal
gepennt hab ich hoffe natürlich dass
video durchgefallen ihr könnt mir super
gerne weiter hotel so also in die
kommentare schreiben aber irgendwas
anderes was ich mal testen soll gerne
auch irgendwo in deutschland ich habe
nämlich bock ein bisschen rum zu kommen
das war es von mir und dem artikel in
berlin leute haut rein